hey what's up my name's samuel lee and
i'm amanda lee we got a massive
announcement today what happened we have
just completed on buying our dream home
we've just bought this house three
million pounds it's ours we bought it
it's the very first time we've done that
i know i'm so excited we buy a lot of
houses we buy a lot of properties but
this is the very first time that we've
ever bought a house that we're actually
gonna live in we loved it so much so in
this video we're gonna talk about why we
bought it how much it costs what the
crack is what the plans are with it the
development i'm so excited i'm well done
i'm really really really excited really
really just before christmas let's go
we'll show you around so one of the
things that i loved about the house was
just the garden it's not too big it's
not too small it's just perfect for us
and the kids and since then we've put
money we've put money into it you know
we bought a 30 000 pound swim spa in the
garden and i love the fact that you can
just walk around that in fact let's just
do a quick spin around the front of the
house so mandy's got her nice
environmental friendly electric car yes
and the thing is when you're renting
like some people think oh you can't do
anything to the house i think you can
like we put sockets in i don't know how
much this cost maybe like a couple grand
was it no it was like 600 pounds okay
but we we spent money around the house
but we kind of like emotionally got to
the point where we thought we don't want
to leave here
and the landlord three months ago said
to us
we're going to come back from singapore
we want to live in the house again
was like no no no this isn't going to
happen man what can we do and uh we just
walk around and then we'll tell the
story the location as well where we are
is like prime location right yeah it's
lovely lovely little spots in
buckinghamshire 20 minutes outside
london i love it we've got a little park
that we've put for the kids
there's
i'm thinking that i'm thinking this the
swim spa i'm thinking we can put this
into the ground now what do you reckon
so and then we can have like proper
decking around it have some little sun
lounge a chair put it into the ground
we've got a few developments we're going
to be potentially doing on the house so
you know maybe you can guess what that
is planning planning planning permission
uh permitting so uh no absolutely
fabulous i love this place i love it at
christmas i love it in summer i know all
year round i just feel like it's just
lovely there's like usually there's some
places where you can live and when it's
like winter it's like oh dark and dingy
but this is just like light airy yeah
fresh amazing so let's head on in
hey hello
[Laughter]
so we just put this thing up in fact
mandy tell them a story about how we got
this tray so we walked into the shop we
were looking for a christmas tree and
this one was actually on display and it
was just plain it didn't have any of the
decorations on and we were just like we
want that tree and they were like are
you sure and we were like yeah and they
were like well how big is your house
like that cannot fit in a normal tree
because this shop was like i said that
that tree's that that's our tree this
yeah that's not for sale yeah mandy's
like everything's for sale even this
house is for sale everything has a price
everything has a price now look we're
not going to tell you in every single
room in the house here because we've got
a lot of rooms this is this is my office
this is where i do my work this is like
my magic nania room i'm going and work
gets done we've got downstairs toilet
cctv room um this is where i was going
to have my office
oh yeah
watch the previous house tour then
you'll know amanda would not let me have
this is my uh no my studio i wanted to
have this as like a filming room but
we've actually should we tell them what
we did what was crazy go on do you know
what i'm talking about no i'm not sure
you're going with it our other house our
other new house all right yeah so we've
rented another house
down the road from here
really nice mansion which is basically
like my studio like it's where i do
loads of offices because the thing is
with this house it was like bringing
people here all the time i still bring
some students here like if they do
really well they're a friend but we've
got another house that we rent where we
just do parties and filming and crazy
madness down the road but this room
we're gonna get this changed up i know i
really really want to modernize it i
want to change the surface
really spruce up a bit we got these
sofas so many years ago and they have
lasted us wow yeah we got them when we
lived in the barn and
so we've had them a long time and
they've served us well but i think now
it's time to like just switch things up
completely and just make them a bit more
i mean literally this whole mandy wants
to just change this entire i personally
quite like it manny come come and talk
about what you're thinking of doing like
all around here through to the kitchen
so another thing so the flooring at the
moment is like a wood floor but i think
it would look so much better if it was
like a marble so like white marble
flooring i think when you walk in it
would just look even more grander it's
really nice especially with the big open
foyer that we have so mandy wants to
mandy's like a bit of an interior
designer
surveyor so mandy wants to get as you
walk in white marble floor all through
here right running down through to the
kitchen so this will all be new we're
going to get new flooring mandy wants to
get a new kitchen personally i don't see
what's wrong with this kitchen what are
you wanting to do this kitchen's great
but i want it to be even more light and
bright so white cabinets with like gold
detail
i just think that would look so much
better nice marble work tops as well i
think this will look like in a whole
even new house in like maybe six months
time so we've got through here this is
the kids play area we've got a whole
nother section to the house i'll tell
you something when we first moved in
here i lost amanda because i didn't
realize that we had a whole utility area
i was looking for like 45 minutes she's
like i'm in the utility i'm like what i
literally didn't know that part of the
house existed true story yeah true story
i can testify to another thing i'll say
is i didn't even before we moved in this
mandy found this house before we moved
into this house
i had i haven't seen it once maybe once
yeah you've seen this one but you but
we've moved into houses before where he
hasn't i've literally viewed it and
you've just gone on my sister so how did
this come about then how did how did we
end up buying this house yeah so we
basically had notification from the
agent saying that the landlord wants to
move back into their family home the
annoying thing was we'd start we just
signed a two-year yeah agreement and we
were like yes yes but then the landlord
said we want to put in a six-month break
clause though we're like oh no
sixth month comes the landlord says
we're moving back from singapore into
the house on amanda's birthday and i was
just thinking no because we truly made
it our home and we love this house so
much so settled in the area so then we
just you know said you know we want to
buy it i know it's not on the market but
are you open to that and they were like
they were like the landlord would
consider what you're offering so we got
the place valued i think we actually got
a good deal i think we negotiated a good
deal um the landlord was cool yeah and
we got it for three million pounds we
put a million pound cash we've got a two
million pound mortgage
the more it made sense to get a mortgage
because the interest rates are
ridiculous
it's like free money yeah and i'll
always advise
not to buy a house where you're living
okay so i need to say this i need to say
this
you should never put your earned income
into buying a luxury
buying a house to live in is a luxury so
our security and it feels nice because
it's yours it's kind of luxury it makes
commercial sense to rent it we pay seven
and a half thousand pounds of rent for
this yeah the mortgage payments to be
fair because interest rates are so
ridiculous or less than that but we had
to type a lot of cash doing this makes
sense to rent somewhere commercially but
we did not buy this with our earned
income we bought this with our passive
income you shouldn't buy range rovers
fancy holidays anything with your
earnings what you should do is you
should work hard on a job on a business
whatever it is and then invest that
money into property i mean you've been
working so hard with the guys on the
property side of the business
lockdown was a crazy crazy time yeah
work through that time is paying off now
we're seeing the fruits because here's
the thing right like man it's so good
isn't it i love this this this this is a
nice tray this is a nice tray um
the thing is this like
through lockdown
our training company
was losing money like i had to at one
point sell off some of my little houses
some of our houses yeah to do what to
pay the wages to pay the weight to give
everything a float and lots of training
companies when you can't run events we
can't we're going bust
all of our staff we looked after them we
kept everybody going we
our customers our students while
everyone else was sort of serviced
accommodation we're struggling hotels
we're closing down
all the service accommodation training
companies we're just like whoa i'll just
wait for this to finish what was i doing
locking myself in the office ringing up
my students checking okay
meanwhile the property side of things
was blowing up i know it was really
booming our development what you've been
doing
finding sites um and then you know
praising them finding what's good and
then literally securing them so now at
the moment we've got eight deals in the
buckinghamshire area eight development
sites and then obviously we had the
lincoln plots you know the houses they
sold most
of those have sold so yeah i mean i
think the development side property
basically i feel saved us through
lockdown it did and also as well i'll
say this this is mandy's hard work as
well because when me and amanda got
married
i wasn't even a millionaire like i was
doing okay
but we together over the last sort of
seven years we've blown up you work i
talk a lot about like deals and i talk
mandy just quietly gets on and the sites
that we've got you know we've been
getting planning permission and we'll
maybe you don't like documenting um some
of the because with property development
with these big deals it's a little bit
more sensitive with the planning
permission the councils and what you're
working on but we've got a lot of
interesting stuff deals we've been
working on been making making a lot of
money and this is the fruit of our labor
we've bought this house during a
pandemic i know i know considering that
you know yeah
which
everything's just been so the world was
stopped wasn't it with kovid absolutely
crazy yeah
the funny thing is as well we didn't
even tell anybody really that we're
doing this did we no the thing is one of
the things i've learned is not i used to
be quite out there with like what i'm
doing what i'm working on out there but
i think i've actually learned
don't tell people what you're going to
do
just show them what you did we didn't
tell hardly anybody we didn't say we're
going to buy this house
like some of the sites we've got going
on we don't say oh look what we're doing
we're going to build these we're going
to it's just like let's just do it and
then let's and then maybe we can tell
people once we've done it or maybe we
cannot maybe we can keep it quiet but
i'm really really really happy and as
well i mean
make sure that you don't put all of your
money into buying a house to live in
before you firstly got yourself i'm so
glad i invested every single penny of
our money into business into real estate
literally people take the mickey at me
like oh wow why don't you wear fancy
clothes why don't you wear jewelry why
don't you have lambos i'm like
because all our money is tied up in
property you know so we put every penny
right yeah we do i mean people saw we
could we could show you a tour of the uh
of the walking wardrobe what would it be
filled with
sales perlers oh my goodness it just
befilled my polos nothing impressive but
that's the thing i think you know make
money work hard for you and i think we
this is our christmas gift to ourself
now yeah so so so pleased and happy that
this is how we start in the new year so
merry christmas to you
and uh listen i hope this has been
inspiring to you guys the last thing we
want to do is try and like show off or
brag um we've we both started with
nothing we've built up what we've got
we've got them we've saved the money up
over this over a lock down yeah you are
grinding using the quantity surveyor
skills and uh you know business is now
booming i'm really excited to be able to
have opened our training company back up
as well and we're running events and
it's just amazing so uh be inspired and
i know it's a little early but merry
christmas merry christmas guys bye